اهلا بكم نبدا بالاخبار العاجله حيث قال
مصدر مطالع للتلفزيون الايراني ان طهران
تدين الهجوم الباكستاني الذي وقع صباح
اليوم على منطقه سراوان جنوب شرقي البلاد
وانها طالبت باكستان بتوضيح سريع بشان
الحادث وقال المساعد الامني لمحافظه
سيستان وبلوشستان الايرانيه ان انفجارات
وقعت في اطراف مدينه سروان قرب الحدود مع
باكستان نتيجه ضربه صاروخيه باكستانيه
وافاد المساعد الامني لمحافظ سيستان
وبلوشستان بمقتل ثلاثه نساء واربعه اطفال
في الانفجارات التي شهدتها منطقه سروان
وقد نقل مراسل الجزيره في باكستان عن
مصادر ان الجيش الباكستاني شن ضربات على
سته اهداف داخل ثلاثه مواقع بعمق 40 الى
50 يلت داخل الاراضي الايرانيه في الساعات
الاولى من صباح
اليوم مريم بكل تاكيد هناك عمل على
مستويات متعدده هناك العمل على المستوى
الامني والعسكري لرصد هذه العمليه الخسائر
الناجمه عن هذه العمليه والمواقع التي
استهدفت وبكل تاكيد هناك شق سياسي يريد ان
يتعاطى مع المعطى الجديد وهو الهجوم
الباكستاني على اراضي
حدوديه مع باكستان وداخل التراب الايراني
بكل تاكيد الحديث الان على الجانب الامني
والعسكري لخصه المعاون السياسي والامني
لمحافظه سيستان وبلوشستان حينما تحدث على
ان الهجمات التي قامت بها باكستان هي
عباره عن ضربه صاروخيه استهدفت موقعين
بمنطقه سروان الحديث هنا على ان الخسائر
شملت موقعا دون الاخر الموقع الذي شملته
الخسائر اد الى الى مقتل سبعه اشخاص ثلاث
نساء واربعه اطفال هؤلاء الاشخاص هم غير
ايرانيين ويعتقد كذلك بحسب المعلومات
المتوفره على انهم يحملون الجنسيه
الباكستانيه لحد الساعه ليس هناك اي تاكيد
لهذا المعطى لكن المؤكد الان رسميا ان
هؤلاء السبعه اشخاص وهما ثلاث نساء واربعه
اطفال هم اجانب وليسوا ايرانيين وبالتالي
كذلك احداث نوع من الخسائر الماديه في
المناطق التي استهدفت من قبل هذا الهجوم
لكن المنطقه الثانيه التي يتم الحديث عنها
هنا ايرانيا لم تشهد سقوط اي ضحايا او
وجود اي خسائر اذا هذا على مستوى تقييم
الخسائر والضحايا في هذه العمليه على
المستوى السياسي كان لافتا ان
يتم ان ينقل التلفزيون الايراني عن مصدر
مطلع ربما هذا يعكس الموقف الايراني بشكل
رسمي وهو التنديد بهذه العمليه باعتبار
انها جرت داخل الاراضي الايرانيه واستهداف
للاراضي الايرانيه وبكل التاكيد وبكل
تاكيد هناك محاوله من التحرك من الجانب
الايراني باتجاه الباكستاني وهو حينما
يطالب هذا المصدر وتطالب ايران الجانب
الباكستاني بتقديم توضيح لازم بشان هذا
الهجوم بكل تاكيد كانت كل المعطيات
والمؤشرات هنا تشير على ان باكستان ربما
تخطط لعمليه ما باعتبار انه كان هناك حديث
من داخل الحدود الباكستانيه عن استنفار
عسكري عن تحرك لقاده القوات المسلحه
الباكستانيه وكذلك عن نوع من الغضب
الايراني تجاه ما قامت به ايران لكن بكل
تاكيد هنا حينما نقف عند البيانات وربما
تشكل الموقف الاساسي والرسمي للتعامل سواء
منه الجانب الايراني او الجانب الباكستاني
الجانب الايراني حينما تحدث عن الهجمه
التي قام بها الحرس الثوري الايراني داخل
الاراضي ال باكستانيه كان هناك محدد اساسي
ورئيسي الذي تحدث عنه الحرس في هذا الهجوم
وهو استهداف مقر للجماعات الارهابيه التي
تستهدف الامن القومي الايراني ربما هناك
جرده من العمليات يتحدث عنها الايرانيون
بهذا الاتجاه والتي قام بها جيش
العدل من قبل استهداف مقرات امنيه مقتل
العديد من القوات المسلحه الايرانيه وربما
حتى الجانب الباكستاني يتحدث عن مقرات
ارهابيه وليس اراضي ايرانيه وربما هو
محاوله لخفض التصعيد ما بين الجانب
الباكستاني والايراني وربما قد نش
التحركات دبلوماسيه خلال المراحل المقبله
ما بين الجانبين شكرا جزيلا لك ردين الغير
مراسلنا من طهران شك